so thank you say thank you for coming on
a Sunday morning when it was pretty nice
outside and also imagine
anyway I'm glad to know make it so the
point of the series is to try to make
math sort of accessible interesting
people and math is all us and that's
what we do both because it's interesting
and fun and also because it's useful
some of me don't hear about are useful
and some of them are fun but it's
important mathematicians talk to you not
not to force them to talk about helping
to useful all so today is November 4th
that selector I'll be the winner today
George Hart is coming from Stony Brook
New York next week and he's a sculptor
and does really amazing so there's more
information on this website or you can
just normal the aerial science outreach
you'll get to it has this end lots of
other programs in particular on
Saturdays which is the program is news 5
at this one okay so February is here
so so this talk is about apology and
we're to find out what apology is why
it's at least interesting and how it
connects to other things so let's start
with a warm up
everybody meet so many humans I said
raise your hands so let's start with a
warm-up problem so in this problem this
is a story
a hiker goes up from the bottom of the
mountain to the top of the mountain he
starts at 6 a.m. on Saturday morning and
he goes up and by 7:00 p.m. he get
through the pink and there he sets up
camp and goes to bed and then the next
day the next day he comes back down he
gets up at 6 a.m.
same time is before and he gets all the
way down by 7 p.m. by different routes
some different paths and then he looks
at his journal he's a very meticulous
hiker he keeps track of where he was all
the time to hike and he notices on both
days at the same time at 1:37 p.m. I was
the same helped exact same height isn't
that a coincidence so he tells his
daughter this story and thought it says
anybody here had daughters or sons
don't be ridiculous he was no
coincidence at all it had to happen so
what did she mean by why why would that
not a coincidence
he was at the same altitude at the same
time on both day anybody yeah
so he started at the same time and he
reached the end at the same time but he
started on Saturday he started at the
bottom and Sunday he started at the top
and he went the opposite way right he
went 70 morning he was the bottom and
I'm Sunday night he was 79 was the top
then sub Saturday Sunday morning he was
a cop and went down back to the bottom -
Saturday night and there was a time on
both days when he was at the same height
anybody else are you saying it so the
important that he started in shop at the
same time right well you think there was
like a particular like rock that he had
to go through oh it happened it happened
exactly once yeah okay well is he
backtracked he could have gotten his hat
come back up so so there's nothing maybe
there's only one place but why don't
that there are two people which are
doing the same thing and then at some
point they have
I see so you're saying put the two days
together run them as a movie on the same
day with a hiker at the bottom and a
hyper at the top and then they have to
meet in the middle when they go that's
exactly the reason so let me let me give
that solution without with a picture so
here's a diagram what you just said so
that the horizontal line here is meant
to give us the altitude from the bottom
of the mountain to the top of the
mountain and in the Blue Dot is going to
do the Saturday hike and the red
triangle is going to do the sunday hike
and they start same time on opposite
sides of the hike and then they start
walking and they have to cross each
other at some point in the middle this
would be the yes
you might yes does it matter how fast he
goes down that's a good question does it
matter how fast he goes in the second
day
anybody want to suggest yes
so it doesn't matter whether the weather
this guy goes faster than this guy but
in effect where they meet right so where
they need depends on how fast they're
going for example maybe the Domino guy
is so fast that he gets three-quarters
the way down before the optical guy gets
even one quarter and then they'll meet
near that side or might go the other so
the exact time that they need is not it
depends on their speed about the fact
that they meet doesn't depend on their
speed okay so so let me make let me
sorry the two two points one is that we
simplified because this problem with
mountains and hiking and camping and all
kinda stuff you took away all that stuff
and we tried to simplify it down to the
essence okay instead that's that's
that's repeated with any math problem
you have some complicated real world
scenario you cut away all the stuff that
doesn't matter for your coming figure
out and then you do the second point is
that even a bunch of the math stuff
doesn't matter so speed distances the
exact geometry of the trail those things
don't matter all that matters is where
things are what is on which side of what
in what is forced to intersect water in
position in placement or the only things
that matter for this problem okay so
this is very hyper definition so the
word topos means place
you've seen this word in a topographical
map which is not the same as the policy
a topographical map uses the same route
so close so close means place and
apology is to study place it's the study
of positions and spaces and and things
which you can understand by just
thinking about positions so for example
a collision is what we just saw in the
hiking problem and maybe the
intersection of two things two lines for
example that's another kind of
topological feature you might think
about where separation is another one so
here's a cartoon - blue balls that are
separated by orange lips so the ellipse
separates the two balls from each other
without crossing the ellipse they can't
touch each other separation so these are
the things that are part of the study of
topology and the emphasis I want to make
here is that the exact shapes don't
matter if you ask these questions it
doesn't matter
for example this ellipse could have been
a triangle or a square or some horrible
complicated squiggle but you could still
tell I mean one purple thought of on the
inside and the other one is on the
outside then they are separated by that
squiggle okay so the exact shapes don't
matter if you're only interested in
these sorts of problems collision
intersection and separation that's
roughly speaking with apology is okay
now you may have noticed I was going
through this I tried to play with the
words me but there's one word there that
I didn't really explain the word space
what is a space so we should talk about
that so what is a space so and what kind
of spaces are there like so I don't need
space like outer space
space is a mathematical object so I
should tell you oh this is what this
talk is actually about what are
topological spaces so what if you look
at so one kind of space that we study or
is a service that's an example in space
you'll see a bunch of service most of
today's talk will be about different
kinds of services just so you know mr.
surface this surface it's called the
klein bottle maybe something just met
the surface this is called the genus
three closed surface the 3 refers to the
3 this is a more complicated surface
that also has some end else so those are
surfaces we also study knots and not is
a curve in space so this is a kind of
fancy and shiny picture of a knob over
in the background there's a whole bunch
of different little knobs this is called
the diagrams knots with nine crossing so
this is the kind of thing that the
public
do they make big long tables of things
so you can see that the way that the
loop is organized in space can be
different and you can name it you might
be able to different knobs apart and you
might not be able to name one not become
another one unless you break the string
so this brings us to this picture
anybody heard the Gordian knot who's
heard the Gordian knot so it's a story
famous story about Alexander the Great
this adoption is great and Gordian knot
was not to see this thing here this is a
knot that was tired and a little ply
with him and he was sitting at night
forgot the name of the city for many
years it was there was a legend about
nobody could I'm tired I'm tired than
you could meet the emperor and so on
Alexander came and he solved the problem
with his sword
he caught it through the knot so he was
not
and okay so those are some things we
start be studying more exotic things
what's different between this slide in
the previous slide is lots of crazy
infinite stuff happening this this kind
of this gas that you see in the
background it is infinitely many holes
and this this swirl over here has
infinitely many strengths it's not just
a knob it's got infinite many strands
coming very close to each other and this
is called a Julia set it's also kind of
deeper than the intricate object this
thing is called the topologists anchored
by a sine curve of the Sun okay so some
of you heard the sign and you know
that's not the sign so so these are more
exotic things let me study I'm not going
to mention most of those before I get to
the actual math I'm going to talk about
I'm gonna make a note about dimension so
we talked about objects we saw have
different kinds of dimensions to them
and let's sort of I'm not going to
define character what they mentioned yes
but let's point out first of all surface
is a two-dimensional object why because
if you think about it it's living in
space this piece of surface but it's
really interdimensional thing because
you build it out of a two-dimensional
object you might think of paper as
two-dimensional because there are two
directions two independent directions to
go in and if you think of this surface
as a distorted piece of paper so that's
why we see circles of two-dimensional
not well not so one-dimensional because
they're curves if you think about
something living on a curve it only has
one one way it can go right along the
curve so the curve of the knob is a
one-dimensional thing but it's embedded
in three dimensions so it lives in our
space which we all can have it in some
way so the way that it winds around
one dimensional object is embedded
inside a three-dimensional object so
there's two dimensional okay and there's
our space we live in which is three
dimensional which means that there are
you know there's north-northeast
and there's sorry a north-south
east-west and up-down exemplar three
directions that give you all you need to
describe a motion in space so it's three
dimensional but there are other
three-dimensional spaces that you will
see in this lecture and there are four
dimensional spaces and five dimensional
spaces and so on and that's kind of
sounds like science fiction actually
montes start saying four dimensions and
five tensions then you start maybe but
so whatever they talk about my goal
really is to tell you a little bit about
where these where these spaces come from
why they might be interesting just kind
of a case of where complicated public
spaces show up in what you might think
of is everyday so I want to talk about
some everyday settings in which you
might see an interesting topological
space now the mathematician tells you
everyday setting you should take it with
a grain of salt
because another intractable profession
but maybe will be convinced
so I'm gonna talk to you about something
called configuration spaces which is
just a word let's not worry about what
the word means you'll see what it means
as we go so suppose you make some kind
of a mechanical movable system like a
windmill
here's a windmill it has lots of moving
parts and it has the veins that go
around and inside there are wheels and
so on or maybe a robot is a more
moderate thing actually goes from
stomata everything out of this robot
yeah so so this one of course it doesn't
exist it's a fictional robots but here's
one that doesn't there's a robot arm and
so here's what I want to think about I
want to think about you can have such a
device I don't want there are a lot of
things you can say about it we have a
motors and speeds and all kind of stuff
I just want to think about falling but
what are all the possible positions of
the robot how many ways can we make a
map of what the robot can do okay so
let's try it let's try it everybody here
we all take our arms put them up in here
what arms enough actually and how many
ways can you move your arm
anybody can do this right
hi and also this this is different from
this right and then there's this so so
there are a lot of ways that an object
like an arm can move and you might
imagine trying to construct a map of
everything it can do okay so let's do
that but let's do it with a warm-up
problem I tried with a clock the only
one hand okay
everybody knows does anybody know the
younger kids have you ever seen a clock
I'm going to give this lecture in 40
years
all right so here's the clock could
imagine they have wooden wooden borders
and and nice all kind of stuff around
it's a complicated physical object and
it here's my map so right now the map
has one point in it which corresponds to
the 12 o'clock position of the cluster
okay now I'm going to make the clock
move and the point moves around you see
it goes all the way around a big circle
and that's the circle okay so my map of
the clock is a circle that's every point
on the circle corresponds to the
position of the clock okay so this is
not may be such a big improvement
because the circle looks a lot like a
fox
it's the big deal so we'll see how it
gets more but a couple of things about
it one is that I've labeled the circle
just be quickly here is between zero and
then I go halfway around I have a
Hyundai degree and I go back around in
360 degrees and the point there I want
to get into degrees and exactly what the
point is they're two different degree
numbers give me the same points 0 and
360
describe the same position of the clock
because the art goes hand goes all the
way around and comes back to the
beginning so 0 equals 360 now I know
that usually 0 is not equal to 360 but
when we're trying to start the clock 0
to 360 or the same it so keep that in
mind if you're going all right so that's
that's it for the one handed clock
oh just said so the space of position
points out this is what I think of is a
configuration space of all possible
positions of money ok now so here's the
command o'clock you see the two hand
before in the organism red and MySpace
what's more complicated you say the
second how it works so let me move the
minute hand around that's just like
before you Steve goes around the red dot
now the right now instead of going in a
circle it's going in a straight line in
my mouth but the 360 remember is the
same as the zero so at this point in
that point are the same point the same
position of the hand everybody okay with
that so let's move the other hand for
the other hand the dot goes vertically
in the other direction and that
describes the positioning of the element
okay now we can combine these two so
let's see let's let's move the hour and
a half way up okay so this one goes
halfway up in the hour again is pointing
to this to the sixth position and then
we'll do the minute hand also okay so
now at this point in the middle of the
square here a quarter of the way to the
right and a half way out describes this
position of the clock you can see that
every point over there you're going to
correspond to some position at the two
ends of the clock okay but we have to be
careful I guess the thing I want to
emphasize is that we are identifying
zero in 360 because when your hand goes
around all the way it comes back again
so every point over here for example is
the same as the point on the other side
because because between this one and
this one the minute hand is gone 360
degrees and a point on this end is going
to be the same as a point up here
because between them the our head is
gone once around okay so that's the
so that's good summary is the space it
positions is a square but with opposite
sides identified or blue we say
identified colleges when they say
identify few things they need you're
gluing them together imagine putting
glue on this side and that's how you're
just putting together okay so let's try
to do the gluing so how can glue the
opposite sides of the square so we start
with a square and let's draw in red the
two sides the vertical signs that we
have to move together to make our space
so glue them what do we get everybody
clear on how that happened just curved
the square around so you can glue the
two edges together okay okay that was
fun right now the next step is to glue
the top edges together now here's I want
to remark the two top edges in yellow
the sort of top in the bottom
horizontally yellow became circles when
we glued up the red now we have to glue
this circle to that sir now you see that
to do that I have to bend this cylinder
around right so you have to imagine a
cylinder you think the yellow circle on
the top the yellow strip on the bottom
and you bend them around until you can
glue them together okay
so if you were doing this out of paper
it would be kind of hard but if you have
a special magic rubber sheet then you
can do it or if you have a powerful so
this is blue the cylinder around and you
have this one circle where you first get
to it the other surprise name with
product is that the red edge also became
circle because so I had this one
crossing point here I'm grading out of
this crossing point of red and yellow is
coming from the four corners of the
square blue together when they make this
one little spot here and this is well
but we don't get out the good stuff in
the inside of the bagel and cream cheese
or anything all we get is the surface
the surface on the outside of the
visible now call the torques okay so
this is our first kind of official
surface that we understand now the torus
and we use the tourist describe o'clock
okay every time you see it to ten
o'clock you know there's a tourist okay
well thanks for puzzle the puzzle is not
on the screen yet but some of you may
have thought about this as I was talking
that I was describing all these
positions in the square and all these
positions in the park but most of those
positions you never seem to realize
because they don't describe an actual
time of day cannot listen it's all the
illegal positions for example if I put
both the hour in the minute hand
22:6 is that an actual time of days at
6:30 who thinks at 6:30
pens any fun how would you show 6:30 on
the spot yeah
if you put both into the six so that the
our net should be on the six and the
minute have to be a mistake to that six
thirty
how many think that's six thirty let's
do a boat so one
okay well now how many things it's not
six thirty so you just have an election
so okay so this so how do you have to
get some city anybody my sake yeah okay
the hour had to be halfway between the 6
and the 7 so the hour and the minute
hand should be on the six because it's
halfway around thirty minutes
the our end is half good evening six and
seven because it's 36 right so that so
that point would be reached by the clock
since 30 but the other one where they're
both at six we've never actually
happened unless your clock is broken
okay so this is we leave the space of a
profile okay so in order to see all the
legal positions let's run through an
entire a fraction entire complicated
okay I'm gonna run the clock see how if
they're both going in same time huh
and note that the Dodge is moving around
many times because the out the minute
end keeps going over and over around the
clock and the hour and one goes once
from beginning to the end they're doing
yes
why is it up there right it could be
here too right
that's a good question why that green
about back from the top to the bottom I
just didn't feel like it so so any place
any of the four corners represent the
same time of day in the same position of
the clock so he left it up there just so
you would ask the question why is it up
there and not kind of it but it could
also have brought it back on an
important point because now let's see we
should make it do that again
once we've seen again so it's climbing
up you see every time the red that goes
to the right it jumps back to the left
and start to trip again
so it's really spiraling up too soon and
here's a picture of what it did this was
the path but if it's like this orange
path we just watched it happen and the
thing that because the question we know
that the end of the orange path in the
beginning of the orange path are the
same point so this orange path is
actually loop just goes back to the
beginning I call it a circle even though
it's not a circular looking because I'm
a topologist and I can't tell the
difference between a circle okay so the
set of legal times legal position our
circle winding around is Taurus 12 times
okay okay suppose a puzzle so here's the
puzzle doesn't see if we're all like so
how many legal positions are there where
they power again and the minicamp
are pointing the same direction exactly
anybody - so we see one right here right
12 noon is a legal position in the
pointing the same direction
and six six they're in the same
direction but it's not a legal position
so twelve okay what else anybody else
24 Sundays a 24 because if you kind of
so you're saying that me at 5 a.m. to 12
p.m. and then we have 12 p.m. to 12 a.m.
and they look the same on the clock but
we know they're different times a day
right
so let me just ask just if you don't
know the time of days you're looking at
the clock how many positions of the
clock are there within the same
direction 1212 should we take another
have an election how many people think
this vote okay not even dumping this
club it's kind of a draw but a lot of
people that were not voting
so the undecided voters of the other
side of days how many think it's 12 okay
so so okay let me explain let me let me
let's give the solutions but slowly I
guess we should slowly because so the
first thing want to do is say we're on
the square are the physicians where the
our hand in a minute and we're pointing
the same direction something described
for me we're in the square with Vita
positions where we're they're pointing
in the same direction yeah
and the line right the diagonal line
right let's see if I have the data - oh
so the blue diagonal line is exactly the
positions where where the hand of
waiting to see direction because that's
where the horizontal coordinate and the
vertical coordinate for those of you who
are the same so here are all the
positions within the same direction in
the orange one are all the places where
they're legal so what we're looking for
the intersections of the blue and the
orange how many intersections are 11
wide 11 why not 12 this intersection and
navigate section are the same they're 12
lines crossing and blue they're 12
intersections but two of them are the
same so the answer is 11 so those of you
didn't vote okay the point I called the
London blue lines circles and not line
why are these circles in that line yeah
because they go around the torus and
then join they come back to the
beginning clear loops good that's a
that's ten o'clock here's a particle I'm
not gonna solve this puzzle T let me
tell you how many legal positions of the
clock have the property so here's a
legal position somewhere how many other
property that if you reverse the hands
interchange the hands but they had
minute hand for the RN was the other
hand where the minute hand was it would
still be a legal position okay I think
this counts is not a practical question
but it's a question so how many
positions are the way you can split them
and still be legal anybody who's not
related to me
second eleven position work last night
the other guests not against then you
can't say yes you need agreement
good
well that's because you have you only
thinking of clucks that aren't broken
but we need to give us positive that's
true right if you have very good
division then you only need an hour if
it's true right ok so I have prepared a
hint and I think you already stepped on
him so here's here's my hint actually
that's not much of a sorry that's just a
square but I'm squirting me so exactly
what you said ok so if you guys can't
figure out on your own
all right one more thing about the clock
before we need the clock for the day
what about a 300 clock what do you think
should happen to describe the positions
of a 300 clock we allow our positions
any suggestions but which of our map
look like yes a speeder why is fear
why spear
your hands
so in each one can be a different
position right so if our clock is a lot
to be broken and each n moves
independently of the other
so what do you think are mapped to a
queue because now three different
independent things so you can make the
min and end go here like before see how
our hands go up this way and the second
hand could go up the other direction and
again you would want to identify zero in
360 so you would think the left square
face of the block thank you and identify
it with the right square face of the
cube and you would also identify the top
square face to the bottom and you would
identify the front to the back you can't
already do that just take a phone with
you and just easily identify anything
that's cold that's all the three tours
it's a three dimensional version of the
torus okay so you're not going talk
about that right now we'll come back to
the near the end now I want to move on
to something new it's not a clock this
related so a linkage is another kind of
object we might think remember we talked
about robots so this is this is like
another simple thing that you might
think of if you think about robots or in
Commission a linkage is a collection of
artists rigid bodies joints had hinges
and maybe some of them are fixed to the
floor or something
and the rest of freedom ooh so so
there's these are actual linkages that
you might see this is the kind of thing
that might see if you google the word
linkage so but here are some more kind
of abstract linkages this is what a
mathematician thinks of when he thinks
about linkage is just a diagram of Rods
playing where you say which ones can
move in which ones Canada you write down
the length of each Rob and you ask
yourself what can happen so the question
is what are the configuration spaces for
the question so let's let's try to play
with some images here's the simplest
linkage more or less than you can think
up so just pick - they're real red
crosses our anchor points so these
points don't this is a hinge and here
are two bars of fixed length okay so
here the configuration of this linkage
and actually there's one more do then
ready to see what the other one is yes
so you want to say chronic the black
this thing and do what with it I didn't
I'm sorry I didn't know you said
but
so you want to move this one to the
other side like this is that what you're
saying so I'm going to describe the
space as follows again like the clock I
want on one side so this dot in our
configuration space represent to this
picture and then there's one more
picture and there's one more dot that
represents that picture okay now so I
can't look that I can't move from this
one to this one okay now so let's let's
make a configuration with three bars
three bars into hangers okay one two
three rigid bars in this configuration
with two anchors and tunings
okay so actually I wanted to play this
let me play this one more carefully so I
hooked up an actual piece of software
that allows them to play with linkages
so I can you see that this point here
everybody following this point this
point they're fixed this point can move
so I can I can grab this and move it
around okay so I'm moving the linkage
every see the weak to move now one thing
I want to remark on couple things first
of all too far the bars disappear and
that's the program's way of letting me
know that I've broken the link so when I
do that at these I made a mistake so I'm
gonna try to stay away from that
but when it's not broken
I get the - I get the to configure to be
talked about this one and this one for
that part of the linkage right it can be
either up or down alright so so if you
start playing this you realize right
away that this is what you can do this
really you can only move this point now
all the way to the bottom until that's
stretched tight sorry and all the way to
the top until it stretch it tight again
okay so let's make up let's make a map
of that so now you can remember this
motion let's look at it so this
configuration I just drew
oh so I've got this name here sorry you
still see me
okay sorry so that that's the first
position here is here's one where the
bar is rotated down a little bit and now
there are two positions the solid and
the dollar okay that's two dots and I
can keep rotating down every time I
rotate I get two dots until I get to the
very bottom and the bottom is just one
time okay so I can do this continuously
from top to bottom as I rotate so the
variable here is just the angle with
this first bar says I've rotated from
the top position all the way the bottom
position I get one that becoming two
dots and in merging into one dot again
so that is the full map of our space to
serve once again the other server and
being clear on that
and again I'm calling it a circle even
though it's not very circular because
I'm the father
well the other thing mathematicians do
is they can add one anything so let's
add one and do four bars so and let me
act again go to the four bar picture in
convinced ooh what happens there so
so what do we do now here's the extreme
position where these guys cannot
complete the extreme is that in
stretching all the way but you see if I
stretched it a little bit more then
there's exactly one such extreme
position and now if I start pulling the
bar back like this what happens well now
I have the additional freedom of this
thing and to think the additional
freedom I have is a three-bar linkage
right one two three bars so for any
position of the first ballpark are of
the first bar I have three bars left
right so I have a 3 bar linkage for
every position of the first bar and
accepted the very top position very top
position nothing is right when it's all
stretched it's all stretched I get just
a dummy once they're cool that's totally
stretched position we get one one point
like this and then when I pull it back
and get a full 3 bar linkage so let's
remember what that looks like
okay so you right yeah so my son is
staying at this one the three bars a 24
barking that you should imagine that
there's a bar between here and here
that's keeping everything fixed but I
use glue okay so here's a
all right so here we go there's a point
at the top there's a circle for the for
those for this globe when I move the
first bar in position other than three
bars in a circle I've been in the circle
why they make a circle this is when I
fix this one why am I not civil in the
previous case right on the other slide
three bars made a circle so here's that
circle and then I keep going here's the
the bottom extreme position is there's
one point together I get a spear I get a
point at the top that grows into a
family of circles to travel to the
bottom merge again like the surface of
you okay all right now that's the rest
in we're not gonna oh wait I lied to you
if I if I if I gave you the impression
that four bars always give you death
exactly that's cheating I lied because I
could make the difference if it's just
the first one in the extremely short for
example then there is no extreme
position for the first bar I can move it
around in a circle and these three bars
for each circle each point in the circle
described by the first bar and get a
circle for the other three so I have a
circular family of circles anybody know
what a circular Family Circle it looks
like
I need a circle right and then I start
moving the circle around in a circle and
come back to come back at the beginning
and join up what do I got
of course right so this is the Taurus
once again making its second appearance
of the lecture so the little red circles
are meant to be the maybe the 3 bar
configurations and in the direction
going around this way responds with a
little bar going around this circle so
we have a porous worth of positions of
this thing ok so and in fact actually
any service can be made to be the
configuration space of ellipse that's an
actual theorem what about five bars
let's let's imagine we don't have that
touristy let's just say five bars and
you have the extreme position discussion
from before anybody when you guess what
we get
he said hypersphere that's good so it is
in fact a family of spheres so each blob
is meant to be a sphere like we had
before and again at the extreme position
of the original point at the top and at
the bottom so I have a family of
two-dimensional spheres that come
together to me a point on the top and
point on the bottom and that what we
call a three-dimensional sphere okay
now that starts to become a little
harder to really understand so let's go
on quickly to six-bar which language
same story and now what's the answer
obviously a four-dimensional sphere
because we have a bunch of pretty
mention spheres and they live together a
family and they terminate at both ends
and a point and we get four-dimensional
sphere now how do you draw a
four-dimensional sphere
well actually don't we imagine that me
if I imagine I really mean that we have
to actually develop mathematical tools
for describing it because yet have to
work with things that you can't directly
imagine now you have to actually have
tools okay maybe it's enough time for
adherence that's try so college but they
actually do is they actually prove
theorems let me give you a famous
topology all the handstand experience so
the hemisphere said it's from 1938 and
over there it said if you have a knife
and a ham sandwich then with one stroke
of the knife you can cut everything in
the sandwich in half namely you can cut
the bread and now you got a ham in now
you know this is not a very kosher
stated in stating this if you have three
bodies in space a b and c just whatever
you want to think of them as these body
that appear because anything you want
situated however you logic there is a
plane a single plane which cuts each of
them separately into two pieces of equal
volume okay sort of like that so
obviously an important theorem for
sentence making but also kind of tells
you things about the structure of space
let me let me try to give you a short
proof not at this theorem because it's a
little hard axis theorem but slightly
easier in theorem in two dimensions so i
should say i mean for it so in two
dimensions what is it you have two
dimensions so just the regular plain in
the plenty of two legions so we turned 3
into 2 2 regions plane and there's a
line instead of a plane which cuts the
two regions simultaneously to people you
might wonder whether there is one four
dimensions or five dimensions and the
answer is yes okay so let's actually
talk about the proof of this theorem
hopefully we can do it in a couple
minutes so here's my shape in the plane
some shape here's another shape in the
plane the red shade and our goal is to
cut them and have seven things so here's
a line that's going to do it so to
figure out if it's ready we should
measure carefully how much area is on
this side economic areas on this side
let's do that we get 27 percent I was
very careful 47 percent on the side 53
percent on this edge that's not quite
right and then on the other side we get
20 percent in eighty percent also not
right so in order to solve the problem
simultaneously get the red numbers
giving 50 50 and the blue none
okay now you might think this is sort of
obvious it's not actually super
high-resolution but it's still worth
thinking about why it's good so let's
try systematically to show this okay so
let's start with putting a line let me
just keep it aligned with an arrow
pointing to one side so I mean this
here's a line to use a an arrow that
picks up that side of the line okay you
know let's record how much of the red
shake is on the arrow side zero percent
right if we give it that now we're we
did well that we should move the Lani to
get this number to be 50 so let's move
it parallel to itself the direction is
saying here we go we got seven percent
that's not good enough
let me do some more 31 percent I'm doing
again and I got lucky
so stopping again 50 percent why don't
we get to 50 percent anybody have a why
why why this works so far
I had to go for it right I started zero
so I'm actually assuming here that my
shape it's fine start at zero and if I
go all the way the other starting at 100
I have to go to 50 in the middle so this
is like the microphone right pretty
remember two hikers they have to
intersect in altitude this is the same
thing okay now are we done well what we
should do what should we do to be
decided we're double-check the right
kind of residence
so we record out into the blue shapes on
the arrow side it's 29% on this side
okay all right so that's not good we
need it to be 50% here and 50% here at
the same time okay on the other side so
so what we can do it didn't work you go
back to the beginning okay and we rotate
the line a little bit can we try again
let me get 50% because that's where we
stopped and we got a different number in
any 34 percent or something on the blue
right there's 34 percent over here and
whatever the opposite what's the
opposite of 34 percent
100 minus 34 racism but on a nice 34
let's just check their words awake yeah
66 right so if there's 34 percent on
this side and there's 66 percent on this
side okay okay so so what do we do well
here's what we do we start with that
position that we were just at when we
repeat this process but we do it by
rolling we do it for all the angles so
this 180 around like this all of these
angles we do and note that when we
rotate the line through 180 degrees is
the same line but the opposite error so
this is why I had the arrow I rotate
every K degrees the arrow tells me that
I'm looking at at something different
now I'm looking note that the
zero-percent became harder this time is
that a pretty clear on that could be
arrows pointing toward okay so so let's
do that but let's do that at the 50%
mark so here's the 50% mark family for
with 34% over here and now we we repeat
our whole process for every angle
between that and I'm going to increase
it back and what happens to the blue
numbers
the blue numbers it's higher the Queen's
number is it 6% since you're not the
right it's the 66 man why is it 66% it's
the same line as we had before but in
the arrows pointing the opposite
direction
yeah
exactly exactly before the arrow was
pointing up and we were meandering this
part which was 34% now ble 20 down and
we're measuring this part which is 66%
so so we've gone from less than 50 to
more than 2 which means that we have to
pass through 50 in that field okay
someone in between that to see that
beginning in the end we have to go to
50% on the blue and we already have to
be percent on the red for olive woods so
now we have 50/50 that's okay and so you
want to keep the same clear in six
dimensions is the same but that's okay
so we're almost out of time I think the
end I want to just walk through just a
bunch of pictures just for fun so let me
say a few words before we finish about
public policy and senatorial aide so so
here's the it's the most any excuse to
draw a few more pictures so here's the
square that we made it boys okay the
last thing I want to think about it is
well another way to try to understand
the tourists is instead of building the
tourist itself let's take the square and
in people Adams if you walk around the
square can go to this red edge and
you're staying a square picture that you
have to jump to the other side so
instead of doing that we could just put
it under squared and so when we go
through the red edge now if you just go
to this other copy of the square is it
nothing happening and so these two
squares together make it easier for us
to think about moving around in the
forest and we can do it up here for the
L event and over here for the red edge
and over here for this yellow edge and
now we can cross all the edges he's
still kind of understand what's
happening in to our point is it
if it worked there tonight I'll do it
over here right and now we still have
some three edges over here so we can
blues somewhere there well we just keep
going right because this is what
mathematicians do you get the starter so
we can just fill up the entire plane
with squares and we end up with a grid
that fills the whole plane which gives
us another way to visualize the tourist
vicinities in this grid are very close
to you later
what like live inside of the course okay
what about the Three Forks remember the
three tourists when before it was a
Cuban and we identified the faces bottom
and top and so on we could try to do the
same thing to visualize the three
tourists and so does this help with the
question and the answer is yes so here's
a picture of what it looks like this is
a picture by MC Escher in the 15 it's a
cubical packing of two-dimensional space
sort of scene the other thing about this
picture is that mini makes you feel I'm
gonna be to live inside of the three
tours okay and
we can do the same thing for other
services so here's another service we
haven't talked about the service called
the genius to service we could know the
system of lines around it
and cut along them we get an octagon
okay and then we can try the tile with
the octagon like we did with the square
but we get a mess you see how it starts
overlapping that's not a good way to
work so what do we do
so this is meaning just just a flyby
picture we can make this octagon instead
of a straight including one you can
build it something called the hyperbolic
plane so this is an advertisement for a
different time in a different talk ever
tell you about the hyperbolic plane it's
a place where geometry is very different
from the Euclidean plane but it can spit
but it still has a lot of features the
nice features there are straight lines
which look like this you can go all the
way to the horizon you see how things
fade away Jacobus rising so here is an
octagon in air and around here you can
see lots of copies of this octagon all
glued together and you get us this
pattern that tells us what it's like to
live in genius do something we can do it
in three dimensions
here's a dodecahedron there are patterns
of bluey for the face of the dedication
to make interesting three-dimensional
spaces and you can try to see what it's
like to live inside one of these
communal spaces if we try to put
together all the go to eager face by
face and making for many copies and what
we get is a picture in three dimensional
hyperbolic space so this is an
advertisement for hyperbolic geometry
okay and so I will leave you with that
you